Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an American independent
science fiction film called “Embers.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In the near future, a strange virus spreads
around the world causing people to get retrograde
and anterograde amnesia.
It spreads like wildfire and takes over the
world in no time.
All developments halt as a result of the epidemic.
Some wealthy and powerful individuals of the
society prevent themselves from getting the
virus by hiding in bunkers.
A decade after it has destroyed the world,
only a few people survive.
They live in a decaying landscape, unable
to recall the past or create new memories.
Every day they wake up to a new life and don’t
remember anything about themselves.
In the opening scene, we are introduced to
a man and a woman.
They wake up next to each other in a rustic
apartment.
Both of them are confused as to how they ended
up together.
They don’t even remember their names or
anything about their lives.
It is evident that they have been infected
by the virus.
The two seem calm for people who just woke
up next to a stranger.
The woman feels like she knows the man but
doesn’t remember how.
The man claims he feels the same way.
They discuss how long they might have been
in the apartment but come to the conclusion
that it might be their first day.
Then, the man notices similar blue bracelets
tied to their wrists.
He thinks it indicates that before they lost
their memories, they wanted to be together.
The woman agrees and doesn’t question the
stranger since he feels familiar.
Somewhere else in the town, an abandoned kid
runs around the street mumbling a melody.
He meets a stranger who asks him questions
about his parents.
When the child doesn’t answer, the man simply
invites him to join him in his journey.
They continue walking to no particular destination.
The boy wants to play with the man’s watch,
so he hands it to him.
He tries to explain the concept of time to
the kid but fails miserably.
A while later, the boy gets distracted by
a mirror on the pile of garbage by the side
of the road.
The stranger walks away talking to himself
about time and space, not noticing that the
kid is no longer with him.
Some seconds later, the kid runs to him but
by the time, the man has already forgotten
him.
He introduces himself again and asks the kid
about the watch.
He comments that it is too big for the kid
and wears it himself, not remembering that
he gave it to the boy a few moments ago.
Eventually, they reach the remains of a house
where the man dances with an umbrella to entertain
the kid.
Somewhere else, in a fancy bunker, a young
woman named Miranda does her early morning
routine that has been the same for as long
as she can remember.
A computerized program asks her to introduce
herself for a regular checkup to ensure she
hasn’t gotten the virus.
The computer asks her name, her birthplace,
and her birth date.
It is revealed that Miranda has been in confinement
for the past nine years.
She is then told a scenario and asked questions
about it.
When she answers all of them correctly, the
computer declares she has passed the regular
diagnostics.
The likelihood of her being infected is less
than 0.12%.
Although Miranda is in the safest place one
can be during an epidemic, she is not happy
with her life.
The routine she has been following for the
past nine years bores her to death and she
feels like life outside would be much more
enjoyable even if it is dangerous.
Another man who has been infected by the virus
is a teacher who lives in a secluded house
near the woods.
He has adapted to life as an amnesic person
better than other infected people.
He has maintained a journal that helps him
understand why he doesn’t remember anything.
He also leaves himself notes briefing about
the daily activities he should perform.
A rope is tied from his house to a nearby
river to help him navigate the way when he
goes out to fetch water.
Back in the apartment with the couple, the
woman finds a can of preserved fruits in a
cabinet.
They might have left it there the previous
day but they aren’t sure.
She tries the food and gives it to the guy
after making sure it tastes good.
While eating she tucks her hair behind her
ears and the man excitedly claims that he
knew she was about to tuck it.
Although he doesn’t know anything about
himself, he somehow remembers the little things
that the woman does.
She walks up to the mirror and looks at herself,
taking in her appearance.
They discuss the possibility of them being
relatives.
But since they look different from each other,
they cut the possibility of them being siblings.
The woman assumes they are married and the
man smiles at the idea.
To test it, they kiss each other.
The passion while they kiss makes it clear
to them that they are in fact a couple.
In the following scene, we are introduced
to a thug who after being infected, has been
killing and robbing people for food and supplies.
He notices the little kid and his new mentor
from earlier.
They are sitting down eating a canned drink.
The thug attacks the man and kills him for
the drink.
The kid is left alone but he doesn’t express
sadness on his mentor’s death.
He simply takes the watch off the man’s
wrist and walks away.
Back in the woods, the teacher reads the notes
and cooks food according to the instructions.
While lounging, he discovers a book on his
desk that he had written before the pandemic.
In the meantime, the couple from the apartment
talks about their relationship.
They think of a name for each other and decide
to go with Ben and Jenny.
They are falling in love for the hundredth
time like they have done every day for the
past decade.
Ben suggests they check who else is in the
building to get a better understanding of
where they are.
They walk out and see the building consists
of rooms similar to theirs.
After exploring one of them, they decide to
return to their room but have forgotten where
it is.
They enter a random room but Ben suggests
that they should find themselves something
better than the dusty rooms of an abandoned
building.
Hence, they pack the clothes from the closet
and start their journey outside.
Back in the bunker, Miranda is exercising
with her father like usual.
He is the only other resident of the facility.
While eating a pre-packed dinner, they talk
about their day.
It is revealed that Miranda plays the cello
to keep her busy throughout the day.
Her father knows that Miranda isn’t happy
with her life in the bunker but his first
responsibility is to keep her safe so he cannot
allow her to go outside.
The little kid from earlier is now wandering
around the town alone.
He meets a young girl in front of her house.
She invites him in and asks him to stay with
her forever.
They eat good food and play with her stuffed
toys.
In the following scene, Ben and Jenny reach
an empty swimming pool.
Ben watches his wife with a smile as she plays
on the slide and skips around.
The thug from earlier is also lonely.
He plays alone in a kid’s park until he
sees a woman and chases her.
After a struggle, she manages to get away
and he gets distracted by a horse and forgets
what he was doing.
At the same time, Ben and Jenny walk together
while humming a song.
They have forgotten the purpose of the trip.
They enter a chapel that they think is oddly
familiar.
After spending some time there, they go to
a room and make love.
At night, they sit in front of the fire talking
about several things.
They quickly register that the next day, they
will be strangers again, hence they shouldn’t
fall asleep to remember they love each other.
The following morning, the kid wakes up on
a pile of toys.
He doesn’t remember how he got there, so
he escapes through the window.
While roaming around the woods, he meets the
teacher and follows him home.
The teacher is not happy about his presence
at first but opens up to the boy with time.
He feeds the kid good food and teaches him
how to chop wood claiming that he is an expert
in the task but doesn’t know how he learned
it.
Ben and Jenny, on the other hand, have eventually
fallen asleep.
They wake up as strangers yet again.
They repeat the conversation from the previous
day and get along.
Moments later, they are roaming around town
while talking.
This time, they name each other Max and Katie.
Katie hurts her leg making it bleed profusely.
Max quickly runs away to get some water for
her, asking her to wait for him.
He gets a bottle of water but doesn’t remember
why he was looking for it in the first place.
He drinks it and walks the other way while
Katie still waits for him to return.
Somewhere else, the thug is in a parking lot,
breaking cars out of anger and for entertainment.
After he is tired, he gets inside one of them
and falls asleep.
He is woken up by a gang of men who drag him
out of the car and beat him up.
Some minutes later, they leave him alone.
The thug walks to the terrace while sobbing.
He sees a person in the street below and starts
throwing glass bottles at them, completely
forgetting what he was crying about a few
seconds earlier.
In the bunker, boredom gets the best of Miranda.
Playing cello doesn’t excite her anymore.
She braids her hair to keep herself entertained
but that doesn’t work either.
At dinner, she suggests they get out of the
bunker to check if the world has gone back
to normal.
Her father argues that they would have gotten
a message long ago if that were the case.
He is adamant about living safely for as long
as it takes but according to Miranda, they
are only waiting for their inevitable death.
When Max doesn’t return for a long time,
Katie forgets who she was waiting for.
She walks away and spends the night under
a bridge.
She is alone, cold, and misses something but
doesn’t know what.
Meanwhile, the teacher and the kid get along
well.
He teaches the kid to ride a bicycle and has
become his guardian.
To ensure that he doesn’t run away and forget
his way back home, he ties him to a roll of
wool and lets him play in the woods.
The kid plays around the entire day but returns
home in the end.
In the bunker, Miranda plays cello for her
father for the first time.
She asks him to come outside with her but
he doesn’t agree.
When the computerized voice takes Miranda’s
test the next day, she deliberately answers
incorrectly.
At night, she packs up her belongings, determined
to leave the bunker and live a life of her
own accord.
She leaves her father a note saying goodbye
and enters the exit tunnels.
After getting lost for a little while, she
finally reaches the outside world and smiles,
taking in the beauty of nature.
Moments later, she walks off into the distance,
living her life for the first time.
Back in the town, Katie is living off the
food she finds in the garbage.
It begins to thunder so she takes shelter
nearby where a guy with a similar bracelet
stands by her.
The guy turns out to be Max.
The movie ends as they stare at each other,
almost as if they remember their past together.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.